[Music]  this is an african elephant  the largest land mammal in the world  so large that it dwarfed our backdrop  while conservation efforts have made  significant gains the threat of poaching  still looms over the future of this  giant species  [Music]  distributed through the deserts and  jungles of sub-saharan africa  their large ears radiate heat to keep  cool in the african sun  they eat a lot  everything from roots fruits grasses and  bark  and up to 600 pounds of it a day  the tusks are firm teeth used for  digging roots stripping bark from trees  and for fighting and defending  themselves  unfortunately these ivory tusks can  fetch quite a price on the black market  poaching for the illegal ivory trade  continues to be a devastating problem  this is the african elephant  [Music]  you